nitesh Jordan Peele reflects on his
box-office hit us
after opening weekend success it's so
incredible and and it just you know does
to show you if you sort of trust
yourself you follow your heart and mind
great things can happen and I just in
both US and in the twilight zone I've
received just an amazing amount of
support from just talented talented
artists and we're really we're trying to
do good work and we're trying to do it
for the fans make their day a little bit
better the writer and director also
dished on the horror flicks wildest fan
theories there's some crazy ones I saw
one today that where someone suggested
that the ambulance motif was somehow
related to me playing the EMT and Little
Fockers which is like a two-minute scene
was like my first scene in film and I
will neither confirm or deny that my
Little Fockers EMT guy is being
referenced in us see you're on that son
was switched Tim I see what you're going
for we're not gonna talk about that one
right now let's just leave loose just
let that one float he caught up with
Jordan on the red carpet at the premiere
of his new project The Twilight Zone
reboot which he narrates I hope I hope
Serling would approve we certainly tried
to take his mission statement of
bringing entertaining fun spooky stories
with a little bit of like a the comedic
wink underneath and you know we're
trying to bring these little allegories
that you know hopefully carry
pack-a-punch and carry a little message
underneath if you if you want to look
for the unthinkable is the expected when
truth is not the truth what dimension
are you even in
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]